[Music]
time now for final exam our cutthroat
weekly competition in which we decide
which News personality has been paying
closer attention to the events they
cover this week's defending champion is
Fox correspondent Griff Jenkins
temporarily crippled in a mishap defense
weekend set he's being challenged by
fellow correspondent Kristen Fisher
Kristen Fisher it's great to see you
great to see you taking on a buzzer show
with one hour man well and I want you to
know that I didn't want my victory to be
marked with an asterisk so my own my own
little sling here really all the sudden
that variant tear you gotta say just
sweet Grif Jenkins you're sweet Grif
Jenkins I love it here we go yes
normally I'm going to say hand on
buzzers may the best sling win may the
best sling man is unbelievable alright
so you know the rules by mistake I ask
the questions first one to buzz and gets
to answer the question you must wait
until I finish completing the question
in order to answer each correct answer
is worth the point if you get one wrong
you lose a point best of 5 wins are you
ready I'm ready
ok first is a multiple choice question
American Airlines expanding its
crackdown on emotional support animals
ferrets and hedgehogs unfortunately no
longer welcome on board American flights
which kind of animal has also been
banned is it a parrots be goats or sea
miniature ponies Grif Jenkins goats not
miniature ponies goats
I just like goats ok goats is it goats
roll tape yes sir starting at July
American Airlines will ban ferrets from
their plane and go
[Applause]
now you can't always have to go with the
go
third basic animals I keep what you're
wearing a sling Kristin and I want you
to know I did buzz and I knew the answer
on that one but that is compassion that
I always distracted a little bit yeah
are you ready
there's a royal wedding this weekend
this multiple choice as well the
American bride has learned all about tea
etiquette to avoid embarrassment tea and
Great Britain must be stirred with a
spoon in a specific direction is it a
clockwise B counterclockwise C 12 6 12 6
Kristin Fisher counter clockwise counter
clockwise let's roll the tape when we
stir we want to never stir clockwise or
counter clockwise it's actually just 12
6 12 6 this I did notice I know since
you in hatch didn't leave and had all
the courtiers sitting on her feet can
you imagine the pressure yes you're play
a part I don't know the in the decline
of Empire yes it does Kristin Fisher
question 3 a t-shirt being sold by the
gap is being recalled and destroyed
because it apparently shows an erroneous
map of which asian country taiwan taiwan
china
it leaves off taiwan roll tape please
she knows a gap has created a bit of an
international uproar the company issued
an apology and pulled a t-shirt
featuring an incorrect map of China now
I would like the gap to apologize to me
for what they consider immense medium
what's the GUP so China Taiwan yes
our ji city absolutely that is correct
you are back to par question four
there's still time okay Paranormal
Activity underway in Michigan a man
there says his motion sensor security
camera captured an image of a celestial
being hovering above his truck what was
floating above the man's vehicle Grif
Jenkins an angel an angel an angel over
the pickup truck is that true in
Michigan roll tape please take a good
look many including their pastors said
that they believe this image captured by
a security camera shows an angel
hovering over the family's truck last
week so could it be I was like wow I
mean that is an angel the photos are
exactly how they were taken
I choose to believe it we don't address
that we're sticking with metaphysics
here final question arguably the story
of the week a short audio clip has
divided this nation as you know the
audio has people scratching their heads
they cannot sound whether the voice in
the clip is saying the word Yanni or the
word Laurel today it has been settled
what is the actual word uttered on that
clip Grif Jenkins Laurel Laurel roll
tape please that's rare that's a
recording of the word Laurel from a
website from vocabulary calm the brain
interprets what it's hearing and there's
some background noise that got in there
that distorted it that caused some
people to interpret a frequency and here
correct
it's no insult to grip routing for you
Jenkins congratulations you were rolling
through here and again the Eric wimple
mug is your prize thank you
congratulations to you both great to see
you Christian come back don't I get do I
get a loser month no you don't what you
get the gratitude of our audience that's
it for this week's final exam follow the
news each week tune in every Thursday to
see if you can beat the news
professionals at their own game